hello everyone and yes you've
read it correctly i am taking a little
break from youtube and it's not very
often that i uh take breaks from youtube
but when i do it it is for a good reason
but i'm gonna address this
at uh the end of the video before we're
gonna check out the game so it's a game
from
uh yesterday's banter blitz session uh
it's the semi-finals magnus carlson
versus levon aaron
to decide who will face uh wesley so in
the finals of the chess 24 banter blitz
sessions
uh and it's one of the games that i've
chosen there were a lot of games to
choose from i decided to show this one
because it's
well just really nice hope you guys
agree yeah so let's just
dive straight into it magnus has the
white pieces
and he opens with d4 we have knight to
f6 by 11
knight to f3 and the g6 now bishop to f4
magnus goes for his london system setup
and bishop to g7
uh we have e3 and c5 now immediately
striking in the center
c3 strengthening the center and now a
capture in the center captures captures
and here 11
castles we have knight to c3 by magnus
and d6 uh in the future one might uh
do do an e5 but we'll see how white
develops with bishop to e2
uh and knight the c6 now and here magnus
castles and
there is one game in the database it was
from the russian blitz championship
where bishop f5 was played
vladislav artemis played it against
boris garage of the game ended in a draw
in 2017 but here we have knight the h511
and it is as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see uh what this means for us
the viewers uh so the bishop is under
attack you can either go bishop to g3
but first
bishop the g5 now asking do you want to
create further weaknesses on the king
side
and 11 says yeah no problem i definitely
want to get rid of that bishop
bishop to h4 and now g5 so here
the idea is we're going to kick away the
bishop to g3 and then trade off our
knight for bishop but magnus says nope
let's go d5 instead and what's happening
here now
now you could move the knight there are
some lines where for example you can go
knight to b
for a three knight captures on d5 and
then capture the bishop
you could just play g captures on h4 you
could go with the knight to the a5 so a
lot of possibilities here
uh however 11 goes for g captures on h4
and it seems like you're opening up your
king too much but since you've just
grabbed the white's dark square bishop
you're not really all that worried uh so
first magnus doesn't recapture on c6
first knight captures on h4
because you're either going to capture
the knight on c6 or the knight on h5 so
here we have knight
to f6 and d captures on c6 grabbing back
the piece now b
captures and rook to c1 so here like i
said
uh eleven's the king side is a bit open
but magnus without a dark square bishop
not all that uh much to worry about so
rogue b8
developing while attacking and b3 magnus
defends we have queen to a5
now putting some pressure if the knight
moves you can pick up the a2 pawn
and here knight the a4 uh we have
c5 as now the c6 pawn is under attack so
eleven defends it c5 and
queen to d3 now uh a nice developing
move by the queen preventing the natural
developing bishop the f5 move
also with the knight and the queen so
the knight cannot also move plus you
want to play uh knights to f5 at some
point
as uh you don't have only one knight on
the rim but actually you have two
because
we often say uh a knight on the rim is
grim but
what about two nights uh so here rook to
d8
uh developing and now rook after d1 so
everything has not been developed uh
magnus will decide what to do with and
i'd probably go
a knight to f5 so eleven not really
worried all that much about developing
the light square bishop
uh so first bishop to b7 a waiting move
but also kind of preparing bishop to b5
to trade off a lot of pieces
and here we have knight knight to f5 and
this is where the
magic really happens uh because here
bishop to b5 uh is
is uh what you want to do bishop to b5
and then yeah you just start
trading off everything because knight
captures on e7 with
check doesn't work here if you go for
knight capture is just king f8 and now
you will uh lose some material here so
instead uh eleven
instead of going for this uh eleven
finds uh a brilliant uh
attacking move c4 and now everything uh
is hanging so this is hanging
this is hanging as you can see it's uh
attacked twice
uh you you cannot capture the pawn the
knight will be hanging so
everything is hanging however it's uh
it's a great attacking move that
basically loses the game but this is
only one of the positive video moments
for this game so feel free to pause the
video
and find this idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on figuring out
that
this now works and there's a very
special reason why it works
because the bishop is here so the rook
is not defending the spawn and
this is why this is now a good move so
knight captures an e7 with
check this is what magnus played but
it's not uh
it's not all that simple it's really
it's a unique line and
only one way to play it so king to f8
and now comes
rook captures on c4 so the queen is no
longer under attack and you will give up
the knight but it doesn't matter king
captures an e7 you have to capture
otherwise you've just
uh i mean you've done nothing uh so
queen captures on d6 this would not be
possible if bishop
moved to b5 in the line that we've
mentioned because then the rook would be
defending the d6 pawn so queen captures
on d6 with
check king to e8 only move and now uh
how do you continue this attack uh feel
free to pause the video
and continue the attack for white
there's only one good way to do it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not only
spotting the idea on the first
positivity moment but also continuing
the attack properly and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook to c5 now the queen is under attack
and you're threatening rook to e5 with
check and it's not an easy way out so
queen to b4
now uh saying okay you can deliver your
check we're going to trade queens i'm
going to block with bishop to e6 so not
a problem
here bishop rook to e5 with check
also adding an attack to the queen
putting pressure on the rule but it
doesn't matter because everything is
defended so bishop to e6 only move the
king cannot move the queen cuts off this
diagonal
bishop to e6 and now how do you
finish the attack feel free to pause the
video for a third time and
win the game for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on again
spotting the only winning move uh and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show
it's a bishop to be 5 with check
this not only delivers check but also uh
forces black to make some very nasty
decisions for example
uh if you move the king which you kind
of
can't really do because the queen covers
this diagonal like we said
but if you block uh with the ro you
cannot block with the bishop the bishop
is pinned but
if you block with for example the rook
then just queen captures or with the
the knight doesn't really matter because
the rook no longer guards uh
the queen on b4 so what else can you do
you could play
rook captures on b5 which is a
possibility just capture that but then
you get rook capture 78 checkmated there
is no rook on b8 to defend the rook on
d8
so 11 tried the only thing left which is
queen capture sun b5
he has to trade queens there is nothing
else to
be done here but it doesn't really work
because
rook captures on b5 now you have to
capture the queen queen
rook captures on d6 and now rook
captures on b8 with
check uh looking to e7 and now
rook to b7 with check it doesn't matter
if you block with the rook white will
just trade and then pick up
uh the pawn on a7 so knight's the d7
blocking and now
magnus trades like this captures
captures and characters and here
after all is said and done on move 31 we
have a rook against a bishop
pair which usually is not a good idea as
you know the bishop pair
when fully operational is not you know
something to mess around with however
magnus has six pawns
and eleven only two uh and also magnus
has two connected pawns on the queen
side so let's see
how this uh plays out as it's it only
gets better from here
so bishop to d5 now uh kind of making it
difficult for
carlson to bring the king into the game
because you have to keep an eye on the
g2 pawn so king f1
h5 by 11 and now again you cannot move
the king because this pawn falls and
magnus reluctant to play f3 uh for some
reason
uh decides to go into an end game which
uh i guess
he knows as he knows uh so many end
games by heart
that will be good for him he plays rook
captures on d7
with check so he gives up the exchange
and he he he wants to play a game with a
knight against the bishop pair so 11
captures
knight to b6 check king sorry king to c6
and now
knight captures on d5 king captures and
now finally brings the king into the
game
so carlson with 6 pawns against 11 with
a bishop and two pawns
and well it's just not an easy thing to
play
so bishop to fade by 11 we have king to
d3
with f5 and now f3 preparing to bring
all the pawns here and at some point you
want to play g4 and bust open the
position
uh we have bishop to a3 11 will try to
control the queen side pawns with his
bishop as they will not be able to cross
the dark squares and he will try to
fend off the king side majority with the
two pawns and with the king so g3
and bishop back to d6 just keeping an
eye on the dark squares preventing h3
because then you can just eliminate this
guy here
so a4 you can't uh prevent all the pawns
from being pushed
bishop to b4 again keeping an eye on the
on on the dark squares
h3 now now you don't have control of the
g3 pawn so bishop to e1
going after the pawn but now g4
with captures captures and now you could
either capture
and then after magnus captures he gets a
pass g pawn
or uh 11 played h4 uh which again gives
carlson a pass g pawn so now he has a
pass jeep on a past e pawn a pass
deep on in the past a pawn against the
bishop and king so can the king and
bishop stop
all those past pawns uh e for with check
we have king to e5 if you go here then
the g pawn
g5 pawn marches forward is not going to
be easy to stop this as the king also
covers the c3 square
so king e5 but still g5 and you want to
remember this when you have
two pawns with one square apart uh they
are able to create uh sorry we're going
to use the red they're
able to create a wall here against the
king so the king cannot approach the g
pawn so bishop to a5 just wasting a move
keeping an eye on the dark squares on
the queen side
and now king to c4 preparing to push the
b pawn so pressure back to d2
attacking the pawn and now g6 uh king to
f6
and now b4 just uh advancing those
past pawns king captures on g6 and now
a5 b5
although you put your pawns on light
squares is still winning but a5 just
makes more sense
so here king the g5 and now a6
uh we have bishop to e3 guarding the a7
square but now comes
e5 with king to f4 by 11.
maybe you can do something but magnus
just plays e6
and it was in this position on move 52
that 11 iron and resign the game
as there is nothing more to be done it's
impossible to stop all the pawns
and you can't even reach this pawn you
cannot go here and even if you could you
can't keep an eye on this pawn i mean it
is just uh
just crazy but i really like the game uh
halloween found that brilliant attacking
move c5
magnus took advantage of it uh with the
only line possible and then in the end
when he
could have even tried to hold on to the
rook he decided to trade on as he knew
of course the
six pawns uh against dupont as and the
bishop was
winning for him so really crazy game uh
magnus wins it and he also won the match
against levon five and a half to two and
a half
which means uh he will face wesley so in
the finals of the
uh just 24 banter blitz cup
uh so that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it and i would like to thank
everyone for your extensive comments and
feedback on our chess manga
if you still haven't checked it out or
read it i will put a link to it in the
description below will be the first
thing you will see
and it's one of the things i wanted to
mention that uh i i really really
enjoyed all your feedback
but i got i got the impression that some
of you uh some of you got the idea that
we
that what we've tried to achieve was
just uh get the absolute best theme
possible to create uh
the best possible product while we are
striving towards this we are basically
uh we are trying to spin this around the
team so we we got a team
uh it's not a professional team it's uh
uh
team team that's uh basically never done
uh anything
similar to a project like this and they
are the and they are growing with the
project so that's what we're going for
and i i really i enjoy doing it with the
team
and hopefully you know every chapter
will be better we're gonna
learn more and more with each chapter
and let's say by chapter eight we're
going to be
really really good at this stuff and
then who knows maybe
the prequels maybe the next stuff will
be even better
uh not maybe i mean it's definitely
going to be but that's what we're going
for so we're not interested in like
just hiring the the absolute best
possible people for the job and then
you know getting that no we want to grow
the team around the project
and i think the the end result will will
be great so
uh thank you for all the feedback and
thank you for all the comments about
chapter one
uh that's just uh amazing stuff
and if you have if you read it and if
you still haven't left any sort of
feedback
i do know that we read all of them and
we are very very happy to
uh to get any and all comments and
feedback
so that's regarding the game and uh the
the manga
uh now regarding me taking a short break
as you know uh
some time ago i announced that i will be
taking a short break as i do have to get
my heart valve replacement surgery and
it's it's due tomorrow so not tomorrow
tomorrow i'll be i'll be admitted so
probably maybe the day after tomorrow
and i don't know when i will be back
it's going to take some time for me to
recover
probably i'd say a month and a sign and
something until i'll be able to get back
i would enjoy uh being able to cover the
candidates tournament but
we're gonna see yeah it's not not
something that can be rushed and uh you
know when
when i will uh recover
sufficiently to to join you guys uh here
on the channel then i will return
so it's not gonna it's not gonna happen
before that and even though
i would very much enjoy to cover the
candidates tournament if not there are
plenty of other
great chess channels where you can enjoy
all the action and if you really
uh really can't go without your daily
dose of of uh chess videos on this
channel you can really watch some old
sagas there's uh
there's the bobby fischer saga there's
the uh there's the miho
saga there's the candidates tournament
1959 saga you can check out
the the magnus versus 2013 world church
championship match and also the
candidates tournament
uh you can check out the the short
terracing medina saga so plenty of stuff
to
to check out if you are a newer
subscriber to the channel and even if
you're not maybe you can rewatch some
older stuff but yeah
i just wanted to let you guys know that
that's why i'm not
i'm going to be absent for a while so
uh that's it uh thank you uh thank you
all for watching
uh i would like to thank reynaldo chess
lessons uh like xiaomi dev tv
henry bust and william mckay for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
uh and whatever else happens in the
chess world
uh so thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day